hello games no man sky is not full of
men but it is full of sky actually quite
a lot of sky I got a better look at it
recently and there's a couple new things
that we didn't know about before for
starters there are NPCs there aliens you
discover them and interact with them as
you travel across the universe in search
of the mysterious center you can learn
the aliens languages by using monoliths
scattered throughout the planets or
through trading and the more that you
understand them the better items they'll
be willing to barter with you for in
order to trade in the first place you'll
need resources which you can find on
planets or in space on fact no man sky
has its own periodic table and while it
does include elements like plutonium and
carbon which we have in our world
there's a whole bunch of new elements
that we will discover along the way you
scavenge resources to upgrade your stuff
in the environment so you can say shoot
a tree and collect carbon or shoot
crystals and collect plutonium or while
you're in your ship in space destroying
another ship will yield carbon these
elements can be used to upgrade your
suit your weapon and your ship your ship
is pretty self-explanatory
shields better lasers but your suit and
your weapon are a little more
complicated I can't show you this but I
was able to upgrade my weapon with a
small bomb these small bombs allowed me
to alter the terrain even allowing me to
discover underground caves and
underground ponds on one such planet I
discovered one of these caves and used
it as shelter since my suit was too weak
to protect me from the cold that's the
other thing you'll be upgrading your
suit on planets that are too cold or too
hot you have to upgrade your suit to
deal with the varying temperatures or to
say prevent you from breathing in a
toxic atmosphere your suit protects you
and your weapon defends you so you'll be
spending most of your resources on these
two things but that's it there's no
character levelling system there's no
progression no skill trees all of your
resources and all of your upgrading
energy will be focused on your stuff I
mentioned this before but it's true
you won't be running into anyone in no
man's sky nor will you be able to drop
your coordinates to another friend and
have them come and join you the
developers told me that the chances of
running into another player are super
slim like less than 1% because you
verse is so big and everyone will begin
the game on a different planet when they
boot up it doesn't sound like there's
any true multiplayer but they did
compare the ability to interact with
other players similar to how you do in
Dark Souls or journey which are two
totally separate things so it's still
very unclear and while there is no
overarching plot there is one thing that
hello Games Sean Murray says will be
what compels you to complete Nomad sky
and that's the desire to find the center
of the universe the developers are still
being vague about what it is that will
compel you to find the center of the
universe but according to Murray that
will be your overarching goal I had a
lot of fun exploring planets and finding
new creatures and of course naming them
silly things some of those creatures are
genuinely terrifying larger than life
brontosaurus like beings that absolutely
dwarfed me and some of them were
absolutely adorable but I did have some
trouble with the flying the controls
still feel really floaty they're not
really tight and gently nudging the
analog stick sent me flying in one
direction so I imagine flying will take
some getting used to
I did get a little motion sick which did
dampen my enjoyment of flying through
space but everything around me was so
beautiful it took my attention away from
that queasy feeling no man's sky still
looks amazing the colors are bright and
vivid and nothing quite beats running
through a field of red grass under a
clear lime-green sky so if you're
looking forward to no man's sky
pre-orders are open and you don't have
to wait long the game will be out on
June 21st for everything else you need
to know about no man's sky stay tuned to
game spot calm
you